I'm here with Noddy bubala the
communications director for FTTH Council
in Europe 90 we're here in Warsaw
another very successful event and people
might think why Poland a lot of planning
goes into that indeed the first thing
that gets done is that we need to select
a country because the FTTH conference
moves every year and we have managed so
far never to go back to the same place
twice it is becoming more difficult
because we are growing into an event
that is difficult to fit into a you know
conference center but this level of
discussions of discussion is done at you
know with our board and our members and
we try to see to go to countries that
already have very high fiber penetration
to showcase what they have done to
people from other countries who come to
the conference we have by the way
delegates from approximately 85
countries so the conference could be a
showcase if we are in a country with a
lot of fiber like Stockholm last year
and it could also be going to a country
where there is no fiber yet and we are
hoping to make an impact and maybe
influence the decisions that are being
made by the stakeholders on the choice
of NGA in this country and this would be
the case in Poland where they are
currently making some key decisions on
the access solutions they have now built
the coal fiber network in the country
with European funding and in this next
phase of European funding for the access
solutions they are currently making some
choices so it was perfect timing for us
to be in Poland this year yes and you've
had some you've had some government
speakers you've had some extra case
studies I think perhaps people have
learned a lot about Poland in the last
couple of days indeed and this is also
so apart from the choice once once a
country once a city has been selected of
course it depends on the venue but I
will not bore you with the details of
the logistics but what is very important
is that the conference is the visible
tip of the iceberg so people who come to
the comfort
we have around 3,000 people it's a big
event but there's a lot of work that
goes into the preparation in the 9 to 12
months before the event in meeting with
the stakeholders so meeting with the
ministries with the regulator's the
operators speaking at events locally to
inform people about fiber-to-the-home
about the conference so we have a double
objective we our role as the ftth
council europe is to spread the word
about five to the home and accelerate
the adoption of five to the moment in
europe so the more we inform people
about the benefits of fiber the better
and the second objective obviously is
because we organise an event we would
like a lot of people to come to the
events and since we are changing cities
the people where we are going next do
not know yet about our events so we need
to also spread the word at local events
about our events the ftth conference so
you'll be doing this in in Luxembourg in
the next few months exactly yes our next
event in 2016 is to be held in
Luxembourg in February - always in
February and we will be yeah as soon as
I have rested a little bit yeah I will
start going on a regular basis to
Luxembourg to meet the stakeholders and
we know already we heard yesterday we
had a strong support from the government
which is very good news because it's
always easier for us to organize the
event when we are in a friendly
environment where the government is
supporting our efforts to encourage
fiber-to-the-home
and you've been very successful here you
must be delighted with with this year's
show yes we are we are pretty pleased
with the event it's true it's the fourth
year running that we have reached 3,000
delegates so it's really quite amazing
for a real focused advantage just
focused on fiber-to-the-home but yet we
are amazed ourselves that we managed to
continue together so many people and I
think it's a good very good sign as
current al our president was saying in
her opening speech that
fiber-to-the-home has really become the
main you know thing the main solution
access solution that people are talking
about now you know in Europe everywhere
everybody knows it is the only
future-proof solution and now the
question is how to do it and you know
how to finance it and it's it's very
exciting for us to be in the middle of
this there's I mean planning an event
like this it doesn't just happen
there's a lot of activity a lot of
stress a lot of organization a lot of
detail what are some of the key elements
to make this happening event the way it
is I think what is really special about
our event is it's big but it's a bit
there's also a bit of a knot family
spirits to be pushing it too too too far
but I yeah there's a feeling of it's
friendly because we really make we
really ensure that people have a good
networking experience so there's a
conference there are workshops there is
an expo but you find those ingredients
in many conferences but our event we
really try to put all some additional
ingredients in the mix so that people
really enjoy the networking so it's the
food it's the networking areas and it's
also the fact that we do not outsource
the organization to an external agency
so we really organize this conference of
course we have help from an agency on
the logistics side but it is really our
event and since we are an you know non
non for profit organization I think our
members really take a very active part
in the preparation in inviting guests in
preparing the programme and this is
really reflected in the results which
thank you for saying I think it's quite
nice congratulations and have a few days
off okay thank you thank you very much
okay so there we are
it's next stop Luxembourg for the FTTH
Council of Europe event